Guys, happy Monday.
February 24th.
Time is cruising by, which is not a bad thing when you're getting stuff done.
One thing I want to say really quick, I actually told my, I think a lot of you guys are inside
of Digital Landlords, so I'm going to just remind you guys, if you have not ever, or
even if you have, I highly, highly, highly, highly, highly recommend you guys read this
book.
It's called The Slight Edge, okay?
I'll show you the cover here real quick.
I cannot recommend this book enough.
I've got, yeah, Craig Smith, he's reading it, awesome, okay.
So this is what the cover looks like, okay, it's called The Slight Edge.
I'm on page 205, I don't know if that's, I'm on chapter 14, so I've just been reading
10 pages a day, and guys, this book has just reminded me that it's all the little things
that you do that add up to the success, and you're going to start reading this today,
and you're going to start to implement some little things, and you're not going to see
any results at the beginning.
It's going to feel like the exact same thing, whether it's, you know, let's just talk with
the business, right?
You're going to start to implement some things with the business.
Maybe your goal is, I'm going to make five cold calls, I'm going to make sure every single
day I talk to five business owners, I talk to five business owners with cold calling,
okay?
Not call, but talk to, and you're going to do it the first day, and you might not even
get anybody that's interested, and maybe the second day and the third day, you might do
it for a week.
You might do it for two weeks, because at the beginning your pitch isn't great, and
then what's going to happen is after a week, two weeks, you're going to start seeing that
somebody that you called day three actually calls you back, or somebody that you called,
you know, on day four that didn't answer, got your voice note, your voice memo, they
called you, they're interested, and all of a sudden all these little things that you
They start to stack up, and it's like everything is going in your way, and you have this thing
called momentum, and it's a beautiful feeling.
I have it right now.
I started this book literally a month ago, because I got back, I was in, I remember,
it was about this exact same day, almost exactly a month ago I started it.
I picked it up, I was kind of like, you know, I need to just get back to basics, fundamentals,
picked up the book, just read 10 pages, and then did it again, did it again, did it again,
and guys, it's been really, really good.
I've seen, I mean, I've got a lot of momentum, I feel good.
It's not just my business too, it's my physical, my, what other side of it.
I feel like with my physical definitely, with my relationships, so anyway, I don't make
any money off this book, I don't know Jeff Olson, all I can tell you is that I've recommended
this book to not just my digital landlords group, but I've recommended this to a bunch
of people that I know and care about.
So guys, go grab it.
This is one of my top five books, maybe my top three books, along with Think and Grow
Rich.
That's how much I like this book, it's like my fourth time reading it.
So there is a PDF that I shared, you can grab, just for ease of, I'll just go like this,
the Slide Edge PDF, let me just grab it for you guys to make it easy.
You can just type in the Slide Edge PDF and you're also going to find it, but let me just
go like this and I'll drop it in.
Okay, so yeah, you guys can get the PDF there, I like it on the Kindle so I can highlight
stuff and come back to it, drop notes in it, but anyway, all right guys, that is that.
What else was I going to say really quick before we dive into the questions, let's see.
Okay, here we go, let me show you guys.
All right, and I'm doing this because I know not everyone's on right now, but I'm going
to share my screen really quick for, let's see, we got Craig, Kevin, Paul, Simon, okay.
There's the PDF by the way.
Okay, last week, and I think a couple weeks ago too, I said, hey guys, when you go through
the classroom here, there's this mini course called Community World Map, okay, and I asked
everyone to put their location.
Why does it matter if you put your location, well, you don't have to put your location,
but I think it's really cool to put your location because, well, first of all, it's interesting
to look at.
Number two, it's cool because if you're traveling or you're anywhere and you want to link up
with somebody, you can just go and look at who's in that area, right.
We have over 250 members.
If everyone would fill this out, which a lot of us are in this area, it would be so interesting
to see where everybody's at, so I'm going to, I think I wasn't super clear and I didn't
even know this.
So I thought all you had to do, guys, is go, this is what I thought.
I thought you went to your profile, you went to your settings, and you changed your location.
That's what I thought, okay.
It's not the case.
What you got to do is you got to go here, you got to go to the classroom, you're going
to go to the map, of course, and then you're going to see this little purple button here.
You're just going to click on this and you're going to put add a location, okay.
Now I'm going to go back to another window here.
You're going to grab your, you're going to go to your profile and you're going to grab
this and you're just going to go into here and drop that.
Nicholas Wood, and then I'm going to put my location as Freetown.
I'm in the U.S. right now, but I'm going to be in Freetown in two weeks, so I'll put Freetown
and I'll submit it, and boom, there we go.
It drops me right here into Freetown, okay.
So guys, if you haven't done this already, it takes, what did that take me, 15 seconds?
Go do it.
I think it's so, I think it's really cool to look at first and foremost, and I think
it's so interesting to be able to connect with people and to just build the network.
I mean, guys, we're all trying to do the same thing and we're all at different stages of
the game.
We all come with different experience that we can tap into.
So guys, take two seconds today to do that.
Super easy.
Let's see really quick.
Simon says, can you highlight the difference between the mini course and the digital language
program?
Yes.
So in a nutshell, Simon, this group right now, thanks Paul for doing that by the way,
this program that you're in right now, this Rankin' Rankin' Academy, the school community,
if you are in digital language, you have full access to this.
I think Craig, Kevin, and Paul, I think are all in digital language, if I'm not mistaken.
And essentially, this is just a place to get your feet wet, okay.
This is a place to understand from a conceptual level, the model, to get some pointers on
how to get started, to start seeing some wins in terms of like just moving the needle and
getting going, okay.
But digital landlords is when you do it for real.
So that's going to have everything and anything related to this.
It's going to have all the scripts.
It's going to have, I mean, it's got everything that you can possibly imagine.
And so like everything, if something new comes up, if I'm testing something new with ads,
I share it in there.
If I have this new strategy that I'm doing for prospecting, I share it in there.
It's basically got every single thing.
It's the blueprint.
So that is what digital landlords is.
So this is just the starter.
This is where you start and determine, hey, I want to go into this model for real.
And as soon as you are like, hey, I want to do this for real, then you go in and get into
digital landlords.
Okay.
One thing I will show you really quick on that note is if you, Simon, you should go
check out chapter 14.
If I can find it off the top of my head, let's see here.
I'm guessing here.
Let's see if I'm close on 14.
I think I'm a little further.
Okay.
So let me go right here.
This is the section.
Again, this is a, oh here, 13.
Go read this.
I read this last night.
This chapter called Learn from Mentors.
And this is such an amazing chapter.
And I don't tell you to do this just because I think, oh, if he'll read this, he's going
to get into our program.
No.
But even me reading this, I love this chapter.
And he shares this really amazing story about this guy that just gave him a little bit of
time every single day.
And he started to see himself differently and it completely changed his life.
But anyway, there's some good stuff that I highlighted.
I didn't read it on here.
I read it on right here.
Let me just read this one part, okay?
Let's go like this.
Whatever goals you aspire to, seek out people who have achieved the same or very similar
goals or who are well along that path and go camp on their doorstep or do whatever you
can to associate with them, emulate them, and let their grasp, understanding, and mastery
of the subject rub off on you.
What makes AA so successful is not the information they hand out.
It's the mentorship they provide, both as a community and as individuals.
When you join AA or any other 12-step program, you get instant access to a community of people
who have gone where you're going as well as an individual, mentor, or sponsor.
So this is one of five things I highlighted about this chapter.
Go read chapter 13.
Again, get the PDF.
You can read chapter 13 completely free today, and I think it's going to open your mind on
a lot of things.
Okay?
So yeah, go check it out.
Phenomenal book.
So let's keep going.
Was one more thing I wanted to cover.
Oh, yeah, this is exciting.
Guys, I got a new course dropping in March, just as a heads up, okay?
I've got a new course.
This is going to be a course that, again, for you guys that are in Digital Landlords,
all the stuff that I produce in here, you guys are going to get access to, and it's
probably just a, anything that I produce in here is probably just going to be a fraction
of something that I already have inside of Digital Landlords, okay?
But I will tell you guys, I do have a new course dropping inside of here in March.
So keep an eye out for that as well, okay?
And then lastly, guys, is just a reminder of the replays.
As soon as this call gets done, I upload it to Vimeo, I message my VA, and he waits for
it, he grabs it, and he puts it up within literally like an hour or two hours.
Let me show you one more thing, and then I'm going to go into Q&A.
Okay, guys, let me show you one last thing.
Okay, last thing I want to show you guys is something that I think is really helpful.
So as soon as you get off, you can check this out.
So if you go here, you go down to the replays right here, the replay will be dropped.
So you can see here, this is our kickoff call, so this is our 1, 2, 3, 4, 5th, this
is our 6th week, right, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6th, I'm actually going to have him add the date.
I'll make a note to have him add the date today because I want you guys to be able to
see the date, let me write that down, add dates, dates to replay.
But needless to say, guys, what I like about these, we just started doing, is you can go
to it and we actually put the questions in the description that we answer.
So last week we covered, are there niches that are not region-specific, what is the
backlink data and where is the backlink data from, where are they coming from, like we
go through everything, do one-page websites rank well, all the questions that were asked,
we put in the description.
So you can go to these Q&As and be like, all right, is any of this stuff things that I
actually am interested in or that I have questions about, and then you don't have to go and watch
the entire thing, okay?
Maybe what I should try to do is see if I can do a timestamp, I'll add that as well,
make it even easier for you guys.
But I also want you guys to be on these lives, so maybe I shouldn't make it too easy on you
guys.
I like when you guys are on these lives, it gives me a lot of energy to be able to talk
to you guys live.
Even if no one showed up to this, I would still do these calls, but yeah, just so you
guys know.
All right, guys, what questions do you have?
Let's get into that.
Let me look under the school community while I look or I wait for you guys, let me see
what questions we had.
And let's get into this, okay?
Let's see.
Oh, that's why I already recommended this book in this group as well, I'm sorry.
That's why people said they're reading it.
Book is changing my life, I forgot.
I was so pumped.
After I started seeing the results of this book, I started sharing it with everybody.
Okay, let's see.
I don't know if there was any.
Let me go under the question section, let's see.
There's any new stuff?
If not, I'll go into, I have another place I'll answer questions to make it easy for
you guys, but I'm going to keep an eye on the chat here.
So, guys, if you guys have any questions, let me know.
This is what I'll do.
I'm going to go over to, I'm going to go over to YouTube really quick.
I always get interesting questions here.
Let's see.
All right, I'm going to go to my comments to see what questions we have.
Here's a good question.
I'm going to answer.
Guys, again, I'm going to prioritize your questions.
I'm just going to start going through a few questions in YouTube and then also in the
Facebook group and obviously, school, if I see anything pop up, but yeah, I'll prioritize
your questions as they come up, okay?
So this is a question that somebody had.
This was on a video that I posted on YouTube that was talking about how the rank and rep
business has changed.
This person said this.
He said, in terms of saturation, do newbies stand a chance against seasoned agencies?
So let's just say, let's take Simon, for example.
Simon just started doing this.
I think he did.
Does Simon have a chance to do this against somebody like myself who's been doing this
since 2016 and been seriously doing this since 2020?
That's the question.
Well, the truth is, guys, is that it's the wrong question because this person's thinking
about this in terms of a scarcity mindset.
They're thinking about this in terms of if they get a deal, then it's taking one out
of my pocket, or if I get a deal, it's taking one out of their pockets.
It's a scarcity mindset, right?
The success that Paul has, or the success that Craig has, has nothing to do with me.
It doesn't affect me.
It doesn't take money out of my pocket.
That's something that people get confused.
Just because Paul goes and lands a deal today does not take money out of my pocket.
Here's a good example.
My little brother, he just called me on Saturday and he was like, and by the way, for those
of you in digital landlords, tomorrow we're going to be doing a post that's going to let
you guys know this.
We're going to be doing a really interesting live, a very value driven live on how to replace
clients quickly.
You get those clients, they're bad, sorry, how to replace bad clients quickly.
He ended up finding out he had two bad clients and he's at 10.6.
He's like, I don't want to go back.
I want to replace them as soon as possible.
He actually replaced two clients on Saturday back to back.
He's going to be sharing those strategies.
He called me and he told me this story and he's like, yeah, I landed these two clients.
Guys, I didn't think in my head, oh, Porter got two more deals.
That's two deals that I could have got.
The question is flawed because just because this person gets a deal or just because Paul
or Craig or Simon or anybody else in this call gets a deal does not take it out of my
pocket.
You got to be, guys, think about this and maybe I should answer the bigger question
which is, is ranking rent saturated?
That's the question that everybody's asked from the beginning.
That's the question that I asked.
Basically, the question is this, guys.
The question I was asking when I first got started was, did I miss the opportunity?
Should I have done this five years ago?
The answer is, yeah, of course.
It's like that old saying, when is the best time to plant a tree was 20 years ago.
That one's the best time today.
Of course, I should have started five years before I even did.
The best time to start is now.
If you really think about the amount of businesses out there, if you think about the amount of
Let's see how many new businesses start in, let's just say the US and the United States
every year.
There are four points on average.
There are 4.7 million businesses started every year.
So guys, and that's not even to mention all the new industries that are created.
That's not even all like people that are saying this is saturated are looking at this from
one niche and they're looking at it from one angle and they're saying, oh my gosh, everyone's
talking about concrete.
Okay.
Yes.
If you start looking for a concrete website, it is going to be more difficult to find a
concrete website that's low hanging fruit than it was four years ago.
Yes.
But guys, you're also forgetting the fact that just because you go into a city and you
see my website, that doesn't mean you can't come in there as well.
Okay.
There's so many levels to this, but to say that this business is saturated is ridiculous.
It's still unknown.
This business is still unknown.
You still cannot go to somebody and say, hey, I'm in the ranking business and they know
what you're talking about.
They have no idea.
And then once you tell them exactly what it is, they're like, oh, that's super smart.
You're like, yeah, I build these simple websites.
They cost me 80 bucks to build and I rank them and then I rent them out and get paid
passively.
And you're like, yeah, that's genius.
I never hear anything besides that.
That's genius.
Okay.
So it's not saturated.
At least that's my opinion.
And that's the opinion that I've always chosen to follow.
And guys, it's served me very, very well.
Okay.
Paul says money and opportunity is limited by the way, Kevin said he updated his location.
Paul says money and opportunity is unlimited.
I'm doing concrete right now and see many opportunities.
Yes.
My brother Porter, he started like properly doing this business two years ago.
Yeah.
About two years ago.
Okay.
That kid has only done concrete.
This is like a year, year after we started talking only about concrete.
Everyone is doing concrete.
Everyone's talking about concrete.
He still is getting concrete deals.
He's doing, I think he's does concrete and he does fencing and I think he's going to
that's happened to masonry, okay.
But all of his deals at $10,600 per month, all of his deals are in the same niches as
everybody else's in.
So don't, don't stress on that.
Okay.
Let me give you guys, I want to share something with you guys that I actually found out or
that I, that I've been trying.
So Francesca and I, if you didn't, if you're not following on YouTube, then that's fine.
But you should because we're sharing a lot of stuff this year that's more of like stuff
that we're doing.
Okay.
And Francesca and I, as I've mentioned, our goal is to get to $10,000 per month with the
agency of new business in the, in the first quarter.
Okay.
And when I say we, that means her, I'm not doing it.
I'm not doing sales calls.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm just advising.
I talked to her on Mondays.
I talked to her on Wednesdays.
I talked to her on Fridays about the business.
That's it.
Okay.
30 minutes each.
Sometimes it goes a little bit longer, sometimes a little bit shorter.
I'm talking to her total about an hour to an hour and a half is what I'm advising her
on how to run the agency.
So we started looking at our goals.
We reviewed our goals.
Okay.
And our, I was like, yeah, our goal is $10,000 per month by the end of quarter one.
So this is about a week and a half ago.
I'm like, Hey, what are we at?
And she's like, we haven't gotten any deals yet.
Now granted, I didn't set these goals until the beginning of February.
So this is like two, three weeks into this, maybe even two weeks.
And so we sat down.
We had this whiteboard session in my office and just kind of strategize on what we can
do to make sure that we get to 10 K.
And we realized that if we're going to get to 10 K of not per month, because we're, we're
way past 10 K per month, 10 K in new business in quarter one, then we're going to have to
do some stuff that's scrappy, some stuff that's unconventional, some stuff that's not exactly
the stuff that I'd be doing longterm.
And so we had three columns.
We had short term, medium term, long term was like, what can we actually do to hit the
10 K?
Okay.
This was the conversation that we had.
And we started coming up with ideas and, and a lot of those ideas guys were things that
were not super scalable.
They're not things that are something that you could do over and over and over again,
but they are hustle things.
Okay.
One of the things that we did is we went and went, and this is the one strategy I want
to give you guys is we went in and I have a, so if you either, either if you have websites
that are generating a few leads that you want to sell, or if you've looked at a city and
niche and it looks like a really good opportunity, you've done the due diligence, here's a little
strategy that you may want to try.
Okay.
Is I went in with my profile and I went in and I found some strategic Facebook groups
in inside, in Facebook.
Okay.
It's one of the Facebook groups and I went into these, these groups.
One of them was a biz buy sell.
Okay.
And so whatever the city is, so let's say you're going into Roswell, New Mexico.
You go to Roswell biz buy sell, you go to Roswell yard sale, online yard sale, whatever
you go to these groups and you go and join these groups in these cities.
Okay.
Now, if you haven't made any posts or interactions in there, you may want to do just a few just
to make it look like you're not brand new.
But if this is in your hometown, then it makes it a little bit easier because you're probably
going to have some mutual contact.
So you're not going to look like you're a scam.
So we went into these groups and we just wrote up this simple copy.
And we made a quick post.
It wasn't big.
It wasn't long.
It didn't seem salesy.
And it basically said something like this.
It said, it said, Hey, does here, I'll actually read the text for you guys and I'll copy the
post for you guys.
And I'll, I'll drop it real quick.
Hold on.
Let me go and find the post real quick because we've already had some hits on this thing.
And I think we're going to be able to, to have some sales calls based on this real quick.
Let me just pull this up loading here.
There it is.
I put this on last night.
All right.
I'm going to copy this for you guys.
I don't know if this will let me.
All right.
I don't know if it'll let me drop it, but here's what it says.
Can anyone recommend a good blank?
Okay.
So whatever that is, can anyone recommend a good concrete company, a good fencing company?
So that was it.
Can anyone recommend a good blank?
And then I put space.
I put question mark space, preferably someone who is not super booked out, have two referrals
that need work done.
Okay.
Simple little text.
I didn't put in there.
I generate leads and I've got a website and I need somebody to work with.
I just put, can anyone recommend a good blank?
Preferably someone who is not super booked out, have two referrals that need work done.
Okay.
I've already got eight comments on this thing.
Um, somebody, somebody said, uh, they tagged somebody else.
Hey, does Kenny have time?
There's a referral.
And by the way, this is somebody who's like not even advertising online.
So I don't know if it's going to be the greatest.
Then somebody else says, uh, do you have an excavator?
And by the way, the niches excavation, do you have an excavator?
Is this a full-time thing or a quick project?
Probably not somebody I'm going to reach out to.
Then I have somebody that, that reaches out and says this, he says, we, and this guy actually
knows who I am.
He goes, we could do trade.
I need help with my websites and I want, I want to build two more.
So I don't know what this guy's referring to.
If he, so if he's got, uh, you know, he does the comment before says he has an excavator.
Okay.
So now I have somebody I can talk to.
Then I have another one.
It guy just barely comment and says, we're at, we do excavation work and he tags his
own business, which by the way, I believe is also in the same city.
Okay.
So right there, I just got two people that now reached out to me that want work that
made their comment.
And I have two, two warm prospects to reach out to.
Okay.
If I can drop this, um, let's see if I can drop a picture here, where's that?
Hold on.
I don't know if I can file.
Okay.
I'll try to draw what I'll try to do, guys.
I'll try to drop it in the, uh, as a comment or something.
Let me add Carlo into here, by the way.
So anyway, guys, just a super easy, quick strategy that you guys can use to find warm
prospects.
It always helps if you're, you know, let's, this would be good guys in the situation where
you've tried, you build a list, you tried to cold call, didn't have any luck and you're
just looking for more people that would work, um, where you're already getting leads.
It would work in a situation where you already have a website and it's getting a few leads,
but you haven't sold it yet.
It could work in a situation where you've just found the city and found the niche and
you're running the ads and you're waiting for the ads to kick in.
You could also do that strategy, but guys, it's, it's been like, I made that post
on Friday.
That's all that I did is made that simple little post and we've already gotten two feedback
or two hits.
Okay.
So, um, according to this says Paul says we use a very similar strategy and crush it.
So there you go.
That was just a little, little thing that I tried and it worked really well.
We've got a bunch of different things we're going to be trying guys back to the book that
I recommended back to the slide edge.
It's all these little things that you're doing, all these little things, these little places
that you're letting people know what you do.
All the, yeah, I know it's not sustainable necessarily to do, uh, a hundred different
posts all over the place, but guys, all the little things that you're doing, all the conversations
that you're having, that person that you told that the gym that you do lead generation,
the person that you're sitting in the sauna with to ask what you do, um, these things
all add up and, uh, yeah, they're there.
At some point you start to realize, Hey, that guy I talked to like two months ago, he hit
me back up and he's, he's ready to, to work with me.
Okay.
All right, let's keep going.
All right, let's see.
Here's another one.
This is not something that's a question, but it kind of is a question.
So, uh, somebody said this, I had this, again, I made this video that said how the game has
changed and this person made kind of a snarky comment and said, yes, if you constantly focus
on SEO.
Okay.
And they're making this, this thing.
So really the question is like, can you do this business?
I guess the question, if I were to phrase it, would be that they're asking is like,
how much SEO, how much ongoing SEO do you need to do on these websites to keep them
ranked?
Okay.
Guys, um, not much.
I'm going to show you a couple of examples here.
Okay.
Here's my YouTube comments.
I'm looking at, by the way.
Okay.
So let's go like this.
So I'm going to give you an example of, uh, I love this example because it's such a, such
a great site that I love Bentonville concrete.
You guys have heard me use this example.
This is my site right here, Bentonville concrete.com.
You can say, I just want to show you how well it's ranked.
So I'm ranked here.
Let me see if you guys can actually see it.
Zoom in a little bit.
This is my site here, Bentonville concrete.
This is my, um, math listing, Bentonville concrete.
This is my Facebook page, Bentonville concrete is ranked.
So my page is ranked number one.
My map is ranked number one and my Facebook page is ranked number two.
Okay.
Keep going.
I don't know if I have any more listings on page one, but I, I have two of the top, well
technically in the organic listings.
Let's go like this.
Let's change this around a little bit and put concrete contractors Bentonville AR.
Okay.
Ranked number two and then I'm ranked number one and I'm ranked number two.
And that's not even my Facebook page either.
So I've got the two top spots in the organic and the second spot in the map pack.
Why do I tell you this, friends, I have not logged into this website.
God is my witness.
I'll, I'll, I'll triple check with Francesca, but God is my witness personally.
I have not logged.
I don't even know how to log into the website.
I'm sure that I have the password saved.
It's been two to three years, two to three years since I've logged on the website.
The only thing that we've been doing is the business owner has taken some accountability.
He's helping us to get reviews.
That's it.
We have not logged into the website.
In fact, the business owner came to us recently and said to us, Hey, we want, I would love
to add this and that he printed off.
He went and he printed off all the content.
He highlighted the stuff that he wanted to remove.
And in fact, I'm going to message him after this because I think I can squeeze in for
another deal.
Um, so we were talking about doing something and I'm going to, I'm going to mention this
here in a second.
Anyway, guys, he's like, Hey, can we change this?
Can we change this?
And I told him, I said, look, if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
Okay.
So I'm not touching the site.
This thing is ranking like a champ.
It's glued to the top.
Now, why?
Well, because I did a really good due diligence.
I caught this website.
I built this website the perfect time before the, the, well, probably around the same time,
but I knew business was booming.
I used to live in Bentonville.
I used to do door to door sales in Bentonville.
I saw the houses going up.
I saw the economy.
I saw the cars people drove.
I knew that Walmart had a policy they were implementing where if you worked, if you sold
products to Walmart, you had to have an office in Bentonville, Arkansas.
I knew all these things.
I knew there was also JB Hunt.
I knew Tyson Chicken was there.
I had all this Intel because I lived there and I just made this bet.
And I did the research back, guys, back in the day when I built Bentonville concrete,
when you looked at the search volume, there was not much.
It was, it was a, it was a risk.
I built this thing as a risk and I ranked this website quick.
It was like two, three months because no one was trying to rank.
There was no competition.
Right?
So I built this website and it ranks, but because I did such good due diligence, guys,
this thing is glued to the top.
So the reason I'm telling you this is this person that's like telling me, yeah, unless
you focus on SEO, no, you don't have to focus on SEO.
You have to do, do good due diligence.
You have to know what to look for in a city and niche.
And then it's glued to the top and there's not much upkeep.
That's one website.
Okay.
I'll give you one more.
This one right here I built in St. George, towing St. George, Utah, okay.
Right here, towingstgeorge.com.
Rank number one, towingstgeorge.com.
Rank number two.
Okay.
See another, I, by the way, I tell you this.
I haven't logged into this website.
Look at this website guys.
It's hideous.
I haven't logged into this.
I think we, we sold this in 2020.
We have not added content.
We have not added backlinks.
We have not done anything in five years.
This thing's glued to the top.
It's making us like five, 600 bucks per month.
Not, not anything crazy on autopilot.
Okay.
I don't even think we run ads.
Let me double check here.
Let me go back.
Maybe we run a little bit.
I don't even think we run ads.
No, I don't think so.
I don't think we run any ads at all.
Okay.
So anyway, you do not, if the key is not the SEO, the key is doing the, the, the, the due
diligence.
So guys, for those of you that are in digital landlords, go follow the due diligence process
to a freaking tee.
Everything that I tell you to do, if it says that the CPC needs to be, make sure it says
if it says that you need to look for this sign, this sign before you go into it, do
that.
If, if this, if I tell you that the search volume needs to be the minimum of this, go
and do it.
If you do these, even if you got to look at a hundred of these things, guys, it's going
to be worth it.
If you don't have to look at a hundred cities and niches to find one, it's going to be worth
it.
Okay.
Because it's going to, you're going to have projects like this.
You're going to build five years later, no upkeep, no nothing.
You're making 600 bucks a month and it's still paying you every single month.
Okay.
And luckily with rank and rent engine, you guys are not using that.
I, you don't have to, but it's made due diligence so freaking fast.
You can go bust out 20 due diligence in an hour, maybe a little bit less than that.
And you can go look at 20 cities.
So in one day you could have a VA.
Once you train them, you can have a VA look at a hundred cities in a day, right?
You look at a hundred cities in a day for five days, you go look at 500 cities, you
find five projects to go into.
You can do some real damage guys.
So anyway, if you aren't using that already, go to the rankandrentengine.com.
The due diligence tool is freaking amazing.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
See if anyone has any other questions.
We should stop the share here.
All right.
Let's see.
What else we got?
Let me make a note here.
Sometimes I'll be talking and I have thoughts that I want to just make sure I don't forget.
Okay.
What else we got?
I'm not sure what that question is.
That's in the spam.
What else?
Okay.
Somebody said, yo, I'm 23 year old Russian American.
Let me know if you want to work together.
That's not really a question, but one thing I'll say is that I don't care where you're
at.
You guys can make this strategy work.
I just did an interview with a guy named Pierre, Pierre Goddard.
Some of you guys might know him from some of the other groups that you guys are in.
This guy is in France.
Sorry.
He's from France, French accent, living in Thailand and he's targeting France.
He's making a little over $12,000 per month and he's exclusively targeting France.
Okay.
If you're in Russia, you can target Russia.
If you're in freaking wherever, you can target wherever.
If people search the same way that we do in the U.S., okay.
There's a lot of interesting countries that I'm looking at.
So that's just a quick thought, guys.
If you're in a country besides the U.S., you want to target your country, you should, okay.
Let's see.
Here in terms of questions, I think we pretty much hit it.
Somebody right here just dropping three spam comments.
That's good.
Okay.
Let's go to, yeah, pretty much everything's spam there.
All right.
If anyone has, doesn't have questions, I'll keep going.
Paul, he says, is there any keyword campaigns available for PPC for concrete?
Quick follow up question to that, Paul, just drop in the comments.
Are you talking about like a keyword list or what do you mean by a keyword campaign?
If you don't mind, just clarify that really quick while I jump into the Facebook group
and answer some questions that people had.
Okay.
Let's go here.
All right.
I got one right there.
Let me just clarify, Paul.
Paul, when you can, just clarify what you're talking about when you say, is there any keywords
campaigns available for PPC?
Okay.
All right.
While that's happening, guys, here's a question by Tim Johnson.
He says, I've used Pakistan guys for GMB before and had luck on $300 ones, but dude's Facebook
profile disappeared.
Anyone have a reliable source for done for you GMBs verified?
Guys, I'm not a fan of messing with the GMB, especially with outsourced Pakistanis.
Okay.
I'm all about doing the GMB the right way, the white hat way, the clean way, using the
business owner.
Like for example, we have a business owner here in town and he actually has come to the
office with his truck, with his business cards, with his stuff.
And we've done a video call with him at the office with Google.
Okay.
I got no problems with that.
I'm not doing fake reviews.
I'm not doing Pakistani freaking people, whatever.
And by the way, there's no, there's no, like, I'm not talking smack because this is something
that lots of people do.
Lots of people like to do.
I'm talking for me personally, guys, I'm trying to build an empire here.
I'm trying to build a business that if something happens to me, God forbid, I can leave it
to my kids.
I'm trying to build something that I can, I can, that we can have around for years and
years that can continue to produce cash.
And I'm not just going to take shortcuts.
Okay.
I'm going to do it the right way.
So I don't do this stuff.
So in terms of like do it done for you, GMB, I just don't mess with it.
Okay.
There was somebody that did recommend a, somebody that did recommend a source, but the guy that
recommended it, I don't trust greatly.
So I'm not really sure I would recommend that either.
Okay.
All right.
Paul says, basically any working campaigns that I've been, that have been run for a while
and optimized to save my time, Paul, if you want to reach out to Francesca, this is something
because you're in digital landlords, I got no problem helping you out extra.
If you want to reach out and do this for me, send me and Francesca a Facebook message.
Wait until I get off the stream so I can respond, explain what you're looking for.
I'll put a voice note out that says, Hey, here's what he's trying to do.
And I'll tell her, you know, sometimes Francesca, she goes, she's like, can you not tell people
about all of our websites?
Because she kind of has a little bit of a scarcity mentality sometimes.
And I'm like, no, it doesn't matter.
So anyway, she might want to just screenshot it and just send you a certain parts of it.
But anyway, Paul, message both of us and we'll try to get you something if possible.
Okay.
Apology.
Simon says, apologies, can't see an update to Community World Map.
Simon, just grab your, okay, if it's not working, what I would like you to do is once we get
off this call, make a quick little loom and show me what you're trying to do.
And I'll try to figure out why it's not working.
But you should be able to just grab your username, copy and paste it, plug it in, and you should
be good to go.
Okay.
If not, just send me a loom and I'll look into it.
I'll have Ashley look into it.
Okay.
Paul says, there is a lot of scammers out there right now for GMB.
Tread with caution.
Do not pay upfront.
A thousand percent.
GMBs are just spending like crazy.
I lost any properties.
That's why I'm shipping.
Yeah.
That's a great point.
I forgot Paul.
Paul had a huge stake in the GMB stuff and here we are.
So anyway, Paul, great feedback.
Crank head to bounce.
Okay.
Let me answer like one or two more questions.
But again, Simon send me loom and we will, I'll get it.
I'll check it out.
Okay.
Let's see what else we got here.
I mean, there's not a ton of questions, which is great.
Yeah.
Somebody put this, I'll answer this one really quick.
Somebody said, does anyone do this under an LLC, blah, blah, blah, blah, okay.
Some people want to know if you need to have like an LLC set up for each of these individual
properties or maybe let's say you have your, your actual LLC and then you have a DBA, right?
So you have your main company.
My company's called Evergreen and then I could go and have my attorney or my accountant set
it up and have it like Evergreen leads LLC or I think it's actually called Evergreen
Enterprises, the legal name Evergreen, Evergreen leads LLC DBA Bentonville concrete and I could
actually go set up a DBA for each one of these websites.
Do you need to do that?
I don't think it's necessary.
Some people do like to do it.
I think sometimes it will help with the GMB and these kinds of things, but I'm asking,
I'm saying this because somebody was asking about LLC and I don't know if that's exactly
the question they were asking, but you don't have to do this guys.
If you're looking to take extra precautions, then I think I went and worked this out with
my attorney when I was asking him and he's like, yeah, we can work out a deal where anytime
you had a new site, I would just do a DBA for you.
It costs you this much money and then it would be checked off and it would be done.
So that's something that you could do guys, but again, I think sometimes people overthink
this.
I've never had to do a DBA on any of my websites.
Only thing that I would make sure to put is a privacy policy, put a terms of service page
into your website.
Other than that, that's really it.
The easier thing to do to be cautious is in the bottom of the footer, make some kind of
note that says like, this is a third party company that sends business to Joe's concrete
and we do not actually do the work, whatever verbiage that sounds better than that.
You could actually take their licensing number and paste it in the footer to really save
your butt if you're concerned about that.
I've never had any issues.
I wouldn't worry about that.
It's not a huge deal, okay?
So that said guys, again, Paul messaged me and Francesca.
I'll try to help you out.
Simon sent me a loom.
I'll also try to look at that as well.
And guys, it's February 24th.
Let's get at it.
This last week that just passed, we got a little tiny deal.
You guys probably saw Francesca's post, 300 bucks a month, nothing to write home about,
nothing crazy.
300 bucks a month times 12 is $3,600 a year.
That ain't something I'm going to turn away.
And guess what?
Every single one of those $300 adds up.
$300 here, by the way, that's pure profit.
That's pure profit because that's a website that we had a client for, we lost a client
for.
It never was ranking super well.
We haven't really focused on it.
It was just generating a few leads.
So now we're making 300 bucks that we weren't making, okay?
Every deal counts.
Every phone call counts.
Everything that you do adds up, okay?
Go read the slide edge.
Simon, I would highly recommend you read chapter 13 and if you have any questions, reach out
to me.
But guys, with that said, guys, don't be afraid in my business right now.
I'm not afraid to do things that are unscalable.
I'm not afraid to reach out to somebody.
Like for example, I'll give you one last thing as I go.
We had this person that we got on the phone with on a sales call on Saturday, okay?
And yes, we run Saturday calls because why not?
Why not start the day, why not start the weekend with some new money?
So we had this guy, we jumped on and we didn't close him.
I didn't stay on the whole time.
I just jumped off for a second just to make myself known.
He didn't close.
And after I got his number and I text him and I sent him a few texts, I sent him a two
and a half minute voice note and throughout the day yesterday I was texting this guy back
and forth, okay?
Is this something I could do with every single deal?
I have salespeople, that's their job, whatever, whatever, whatever.
Should I be doing it?
You could argue, no, I shouldn't be doing it.
Some people probably would tell me I'm stupid.
I am hungry, man.
I want the deals.
I'm willing to do it.
I'm willing on a Sunday to message the guy and just say, hey, I know it's Sunday, I don't
work on Sunday.
I just want to send you a message and say this, that, and this, that, and the rest.
I would love to, whatever, let's talk again on Monday.
I've got some ideas and the guy agreed.
The guy messaged back, hey, thanks for the text, Nick.
I really appreciate it.
I could see how much you actually care about your business and I would love to jump back
on a Zoom call on Monday and see what you're talking about and we're going to come to this
guy with some different options than what we gave him and see if we can close the deal.
Is it practical?
Is it scalable?
Probably not, okay?
To do that with every single client, especially as you scale, probably not, but guys, do unscalable
things to pick up the momentum.
You guys just got to get that first deal.
You got to get that second deal.
If it's been a while since you got a deal, go do whatever you got to do to get that deal.
Go make the Facebook post that's going to get you that inbound warm lead.
Be willing to go grab lunch with somebody, again, not every time.
It shouldn't be part of your ongoing process, but guys, be willing to do unconventional,
unscalable things to scale, okay?
That's how you scale.
That's how you pick up momentum is you do those things, those hustle deals.
Guys, 2025, that's what I'm all about, is getting those hustle deals and getting back
to the freaking, the nitty gritty basics and I hope you guys will too.
So guys, appreciate you being on this call.
I'm going to upload this, the replay, here in the next few minutes and I will see you
guys next week.
Guys, bring your questions, anything at all that you've got.
Maybe next week we'll have a topic specific Q&A and we will see you guys in a week.
Thanks, guys.